اذا لا يكاد يمر شهر الا وتشهد فيه ولايات
امريكيه حوادث اطلاق نار يذهب ضحيتها
عشرات الابرياء بينهم اطفال وفي كل مره
تحيي هذه الحوادث الجدل المحتدم بالبلاد
حول الاستخدام وشراء العشوائي للاسلحه
الناريه ولعل ابرز اهداف حالات اطلاق
النار هي المدارس واحدا اشهر حوادثها هي
اطلاق النار في امريكا مقتل 26 شخصا بينهم
20 طفلا من طلبه الابتدائيه في ولايه
كوناكري عام 2012 بعدما فتح رجل النار
عليهم في مدرسه ساندي هوك ايضا في العام
2018 قتل طالب في مدرسه ثانويه بولايه
التكساس ثمانيه من زملائه وهي الحادثه
التي سبقتها بعده اشهر حادثه اخرى راح
ضحيتها 17 شخصا ويمثل اطلاق النار في
مدرسه ابتدائيه في اوفالتي بولايه تكساس
فيما هذا العام والذي اسفر عن مقتل 18
طفلا وثلاثه بالغين الحاد رقم 27 في
المدارس الامريكيه هذا العام لوحده وفقا
لمنظمه متخصصه بتعقب هذه الحوادث كذلك
السوبر ماركت والمتاجر الكبيره والمتوسطه
تعد هدفا لمطلقي النار ايضا حيث شهدت
بوفالو بنيورك حادثا ايضا في مايو الماضي
اطلاق نار او ده بحياه 10 اشخاص وشهدت
امريكا منذ بدايه العام الحالي اكثر من
200 حادث اطلاق نار اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من
250 شخصا وانهت الولايات المتحده عام 2001
ب 693 عمليه اطلاق نار جماعي وفقا لارشيف
العنف المسلح فيما شهد العام
2020 نحو 611 حادثه وشاهد عام 2019 هو
الاخر
417 حديثا
[موسيقى]